pierre lévy rédacteur en chef du mensuel
rupture bonsoir pierre lévy bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous sur rt france
vous êtes donc rédacteur en chef du
mensuel rupture et il a une de votre
journal
cette semaine de ce mois ci même puisque
c'est un mensuel
7 enfin elle livre expliquez nous
pourquoi
effectivement vous téléspectateurs ma
chance de l'avoir quasiment en avant
première c'est évidemment un événement
historique
sevré exit qui peut-être le seul
événement de même importance depuis la
fin de la seconde guerre mondiale en
europe c'est la chute du mur de berlin
mais dans un autre sens là cette fois
pour la première fois un pays quitte
l'union européenne suite à une décision
démocratique de son peuple
évidemment notre journal qui eux depuis
deux mois après mois depuis trois ans
raconte s'il finir les mésaventures du
breakbeat et n'a jamais douté que le
break site aurait lieu est bien à
quelques raisons de se réjouir
et sur le fond et sur la manière dont
les choses se sont passées même si bien
sûr l'histoire n'est pas finie
ça a été compliqué hein cette sortie
trois ans et demi vous l'avez dit
emmanuel macron qui parle d'un d'un jour
triste pour la france pour les
britanniques
alors je pense que c'est surtout un jour
un jour triste pour lui même pour sa
classe et pour sa caste c'est-à-dire
pour tous ceux qui espéraient encore
qu'ils avaient quelques illusions que
jusqu'au dernier moment il y avait la
possibilité de faire dérailler le brésil
est évidemment ils ont échoué malgré
toutes les tentatives que ce soit à
bruxelles ou bien de tous les députés
pro union européenne à westminster qui
n'ont négligé aucune embûche aucune
entourloupe aucun blocage jusqu au point
de bloquer complètement le parlement
c'était de bonne guerre finalement
puisque les uns voulaient que la grande
bretagne reste et voilà les aides mais
les autres étaient majoritaires et donc
on peut considérer quand même que dans
un pays qui se réclament de la
démocratie le verdict du peuple
majoritairement doit être respecté il
l'a été beaucoup de gens ont cru même
ceux qui le souhaitaient que ceux qui
mettaient des obstacles finirait par
gagner et empêcher nous nous étions nous
avons toujours analysé que le brésil se
ferait j'ai eu l'honneur et le plaisir
de travailler vite et quelquefois sur
votre plateau et à chaque fois j'ai
répondu ça au point même que certains
certains de vos téléspectateurs se
disent mais pourquoi il répète tout le
temps ça puisqu'on
pas sûr ils vont réussir à tout faire
capoter non objectivement nous ne sommes
plus dans l'époque où on peut inverser
le verdict populaire il faudra et c'est
peut-être ça justement qui rend triste
emmanuel macron et surtout vous parliez
de verdi populaire il ya eu un premier
vote du bois existe à proprement parler
puis la majorité absolue donnée à à
boris johnson ça peut être considéré
comme un second vote parce qu'on on
sévit n'ont finalement les britanniques
n'en veulent plus seulement je pense que
la majorité le triomphe de boris johnson
en particulier dans les classes
populaires dans la classe ouvrière dans
l'est dans les banlieues où les les les
gens étaient les plus de les plus
pauvres ont étaient ceux qui ont fait
gagner le brésil et qui ont fait
triompher boris johnson parce que
précisément boris johnson a eu cet
avantage de dire je vais réaliser le
break site avec ou sans accord il a tapé
du poing sur la table ça a marché alors
nous dans notre journal on n'est pas des
fanatiques de boris johnson
il faut dire une chose c'est que ce
président il auto il n'implique pas que
nomadic mans les politiques qui seront
menées au royaume ministre progressiste
bonne formidable et que ça serait ça
deviendra un paradis simplement
et ce n'est pas un détail les
britanniques récupère le droit de
déterminer eux-mêmes les politiques qui
te concerne leur avenir c'est à dire une
redeviennent libres et évidemment après
c'est la démocratie ça sera ce que les
gouvernements ce que les élections
feront mais au moins ils ne sont plus
contraints par l'union européenne à
partir du 1er janvier 2021 ils seront
définitivement en dehors pour l'instant
on est dans une période de transition et
il va y avoir d'importantes négociations
sur le plan commercial mais
d'importantes négociations que certains
prédisent déjà compliquée puisque les
uns vont défendre chacun va défendre ses
intérêts mais finalement le fait d'avoir
de bonnes relations économiques c'est
c'est bon et pour l'europe et pour la
grande bretagne donc personne n'a
intérêt alors un bras de fer ça c'est
plus compliqué que ça c'est à dire
qu'évidemment malgré une propagande de
mauvaise foi personne n'imaginait qu'on
allait couper les liaisons aériennes
couper le tunnel sous la manche et
arrêter de commercer avec les
britanniques
évidemment les deux parties de deux
côtés de la manche ont intérêt à ce
qu'il y ait un accord des relations
après ce que boris johnson a dit et
personnellement je m'en réjouis c'est
qu'il donne
et pas question de s'aligner sur les
règles de l'union européenne c'est terry
s'en sont sortis c'est pas pour une
certaine manière continue à s'y
soumettre par la fenêtre et qu' il
n'était pas question par exemple que la
cour de justice de l'union européenne
continue à statuer sur les litiges qui
pourront avoir lieu donc nous nous
alignerons pas sur les règles a dit
boris johnson alors ça ça inquiète un
certain nombre de de gens qui sont des
des fanatiques du libre marché de la
libre circulation des biens des services
des capitaux et qui disent vrai le
brésil
enfin les legs grande bretagne va nous
faire concurrence de manière déloyale
mais dont simplement ils auront la
liberté de déterminer leurs règles
est-ce que ça va est-ce que l'on ne va
se tourner davantage vers les états unis
on l'a vu donald trump a proposé un
accord du siècle avec boris johnson
s'est alors pour répondre à votre
question je voudrais attirer votre
attention sur un point dans les toutes
les jérémiades qu'on a entendu ces
derniers jours au parlement européen et
au conseil et à la commission on nantes
on n'arrête pas d'entendre ces pauvres
britanniques qui ont choisi d'être
solitaire au lieu d'être solidaire s'est
inscrit dans les médias mainstream voilà
c'est dit dans le média mainstream et
c'est sur tout ce qui se dit dans les
institutions européennes à bruxelles
parmi les dirigeants parmi les amis de
monsieur macro donc mais c'est d'abord
c'est un peu ridicule c'est un peu
grotesque de penser que le royaume uni
va être isolé quand on connaît quand
même là l'ampleur des liens qui unissent
le royaume uni à nos cinq continents
mais plus fondamentalement ils seront
pas isolé c'est au contraire en quittant
l'union européenne qui vont récupérer
dans les relations avec le monde c'est à
dire à plus ce filtre de l'union
européenne qu'il est comment dire qui
les maintient dans un carcan et dans une
entité qui les prive en quelque sorte de
relation beaucoup plus globale sur
l'ensemble de ce monde j'attire votre
attention sur le fait qu'aujourd'hui
même pour fêter le brésil
le gouvernement a décidé de d'introduire
une de battre monnaie enfin une nouvelle
pièce de 50 pence avec cette inscription
paix prospérité et amitié entre toutes
les nations
alors sa part ça paraît peut-être anodin
comme formule mais c'est une sorte de
pied de nez à bruxelles amitié avec
toutes les nations c'est à dire qu'on
n'est pas seulement dans un petit groupe
on est amis entre nous c'est une
politique étrangère européenne à
laquelle devait se plier londres se plie
et londres qui n'a jamais réellement
fait parce que la politique étrangère
européenne
en réalité soumises à des contradictions
entre les intérêts qui sont tout à fait
différent des pays d avec les autres
mais en tout cas
en tout état de cause vous avez raison
il y avait ce carcan dont londres se
libère donc ce n'est pas un isolement
sait on récupère au contraire une
ampleur et la liberté de commercer et
pas seulement de commercer d'avoir des
relations et de l'amitié avec toutes les
nations je crois que c'est assez
symbolique
merci beaucoup pierre lévy d'avoir
répondu à nos questions sur rt france
merci à vous